ready for another rejuvenation video
yeah that's the spirit
so yes we are back and this week we're
talking about this recent publication
multi-omic rejuvenation of naturally
aged tissues by a single cycle of
transient reprogramming
a couple of the authors are heading off
to outsource labs which you may have
heard about recently more popular media
so i think many people are interested in
this paper
so we'll be talking about rejuvenation
again
cellular reprogramming what it means by
multi-omics and because it's me also a
bit on senescent cells which may or may
not be surprising
so my speedy recap rejuvenation the
current consensus is that it refers to
reversal of aging and so differs from
geoprotective strategies that instead
slow down or attenuate the biological
age process
cellular reprogramming in this context
involves the four yamanaka factors oskm
that when expressed in differentiated
cells can refers them to pluripotent
stem cells
cells that have the potential to divide
continuously but also to differentiate
so they were termed induced pluripotent
stem cells
and this is where the reprogramming
comes in as you alter a cell's identity
but this is why the journey of this
video continues as depending on how long
or how much you express these factors
you can prevent a differentiated cell
from completely losing its identity
this could be beneficial as it may still
have benefits in terms of rejuvenation
whilst greatly reducing the risk of
cancer development
or worse teratomas
so you may have heard this be described
as partial reprogramming but what is the
evidence for it and how does it work
well in this case it would appear that
partial reprogramming is reversing aging
without a cell losing its identity so
making it safer and so far this approach
seems to work a landmark paper came out
in a publication in 2016 almost six
years ago now that showed short cycles
of oscar expression in mice followed by
recovery resulted in rejuvenation in
mice and prolonged lifespan in a mouse
model of premature aging
but the question is what is changing in
the cells during this process
and how is it working
the reason information like this is
important is that you could define a
safe stopping point epigenetically or
transcriptionally
so this brings us on to the latest
publication
and the first thing we should address is
how are they actually causing this
reprogramming as i think this will be an
important reflection point later
well they use the mouse strain that had
previously been created where a
transcriptional activator gene is placed
in the rosa 26 locus
and so this transcriptional activator is
always made but currently it's not
active
and then also you have lentiviral
induced integration of the yamanaka
factors that get activated by the
transcriptional activator and so you
need to activate the activator to get
expression of the yamanaka factors and
you can do this by giving the meister
drug doxycycline
so to cut a long story short when the
mice doxycycline the yamanaka factors
are expressed so in the study they
wanted to see what rejuvenation occurs
after expressing the yamanaka factors in
55 week old mice
for one week of expression and to see
what the molecular changes were
one of the caveats with this model is
that the amount of expression differs in
different tissue and cell types and so
some tissues get a stronger boost than
others
one that gets higher expression is the
pancreas so that is where most of the
paper focuses on
and so this is where they then did their
multi-amic analyses
ohmic approaches just refers to the fact
that instead of looking at just one gene
or one protein or one methylation site
you look at all or well very many of
them
so if it were genes it's referred to as
the transcriptome
and looking at dna methylation sites is
known as the mufflom
and so multiomics simply refers to the
fact that they did lots of data
collection to profile different aspects
so they started with the dna methyleme
since the presence and absence of
methylation marks have been shown to
correlate with age so called epigenetic
logs and they did this in the pancreas
of the reprogrammed mice
as well as age match controls and young
mice
perhaps unsurprisingly given previous
studies they saw a profile that fell
between old and young mice
but what was interesting was that they
also looked at the methylem straight
after the one week of yamanaka
expression
and two weeks later as well after a
recovery period
and it seems that the gain of
methylation was faster than the loss of
methylation marks
suggesting that the recovery period is
important for
demethylation so anyway they saw partial
methylene reprogramming in the pancreas
the next omics they looked at was the
transcriptome
in some ways this can be more
informative because we can see which
specific genes are expressed and as
genes have been characterized more with
a function they're better understood
and so anyway they saw a similar partial
rejuvenation of the transcriptome
of the old mice and in particular they
saw a reduction in mtor signaling and
increase in dna repair pathways and
collagen signaling in the pancreas
then the last aspect was the metabolism
of the blood serum
they identified 23 metabolites that
change with age
but only four of these metabolites
changed following the reprogramming
as you can see here
it's interesting to point out that
4-hydroxyproline is a component of
collagen and thymine has been shown to
extend lifespan and worms but let us
know about the other team metabolites
they also did take a look at some other
tissues where there was weaker
expression
one thing unsurprisingly that i found
interesting was their analysis of
senescent cells in the liver
using their transcriptium data they
observed that markers of senescence
increased even after the reprogramming
of very old mice
suggesting that a single period of
transient oskm in vivo may not be
sufficient to rejuvenate the
transcriptome of senescent cells present
in the aged liver
well that's just senescent cells for you
but uh joking aside cellulosin essence
is thought to be a barrier to
reprogramming perhaps due to their
chromatin structure but also
interestingly
is the fact that there's some evidence
that that the secretory profile of
senescent cells can drive reprogramming
so it would definitely be interesting to
see a combination of both this partial
reprogramming
with the presence of analytics
so all in all this was more of a
mechanistic paper than a functional one
but this is still important to do as the
author's comments we hope this serves as
the basis for future studies to dissect
the mechanisms underlying oskm driven
rejuvenation in vivo also it may provide
benchmarking to recapitulate oskm like
rejuvenation with pharmacological or
nutritional interventions
so the idea is that if we know this
amount of reprogramming as both
effective and safe let's use these
measurements as a benchmark to compare
other rejuvenative therapies
so with that i hope you've learned
something in this video thank you to my
patreon supporters and thank you for
listening
you